su médico podría recomendar un
procedimiento de craneotomía o
craniectomía para tratar una cantidad de
diferentes enfermedades lesiones o
afecciones cerebrales su cráneo está
hecho de hueso y sirve como cubierta
dura y protectora para su cerebro
dentro del cráneo se encuentran las tres
capas de tejido denominadas meninges que
rodean su cerebro
y la capa externa y gruesa es la
duramadre
la capa de tejido del medio es la harán
hoy des
y la capa interna es la pía madre
entre las nubes y la piel madre se
encuentra el espacio su paranoide o que
contiene vasos sanguíneos y un líquido
claro denominado líquido cerebroespinal
y los vasos sanguíneos denominados venas
comunicantes conectan la superficie de
su cerebro con la duramadre
y otros vasos sanguíneos denominados
arterias cerebrales llevan la sangre
hasta el cerebro dentro del cráneo la
función normal del cerebro requiere un
equilibrio delicado de presión entre la
sangre de sus vasos sanguíneos el
líquido cefalorraquídeo que rodea el
cerebro y el tejido cerebral
esto se denomina presión intracraneal
normal
la mayor presión intracraneal podría
atribuirse a tumores cerebrales
traumatismos craneoencefálicos problemas
en sus vasos sanguíneos
o infecciones en el cerebro o médula
ósea
estas afecciones hacen presión en el
cerebro y hacen que se hinche o que
cambie de forma dentro de su cráneo
lo que puede llevar a lesiones
cerebrales graves
su médico podría recomendar una
craneotomía para extraer tejido cerebral
anormal por ejemplo un tumor cerebral
una muestra de tejido por medio de
biopsia
un coágulo sanguíneo llamado hematoma
el exceso de líquido cefalorraquídeo
opus de una infección denominada absceso
también se puede realizar una
craneotomía para aliviar un edema
cerebral
de tener un sangrado denominado
hemorragia preparar vasos sanguíneos
anormales
y reparar fracturas en el cráneo
o reparar meninges dañadas
por último también se puede realizar una
craneotomía para tratar afecciones
cerebrales por ejemplo epilepsia
administrar medicamentos a su cerebro
o implantar un dispositivo médico como
un estimulador cerebral profundo
el motivo más común para una craneotomía
es extraer un tumor cerebral
antes de su procedimiento se le
proporcionará anestesia general para
dejarlo inconsciente y que no sienta
dolor
serra para el cuero cabelludo en el
lugar en que se encuentra el tumor
al comenzar el cirujano le hará una
incisión en el cuero cabelludo
se harán uno o más orificios pequeños en
el cráneo
luego el cirujano conectará los
orificios para crear una pieza ósea
circular llamada colgajo óseo y
extraerla
el cirujano hará una incisión en la
duramadre para dejar el cerebro expuesto
luego se extraerá el tumor
y la incisión de la duramadre se cerrará
con puntos
el cirujano reacomodará el colgajo óseo
con placas de metal y tornillos que
permanecerán en el cráneo de por vida
existe una variante de la craneotomía
denominada craniectomía que se realiza
si el cerebro está muy hinchado o si el
cráneo está infectado el cirujano podría
retrasar el reacomodamiento del colgajo
óseo hasta un procedimiento posterior
para dar tiempo a que la hinchazón baje
el final de una craneotomía todo una
craniectomía la incisión del cuero
cabelludo se cerrará con grapas
y se envolverá a su cabeza con bandas
si se sometió a una craneotomía en una
fecha posterior se le realizará otro
procedimiento denominado craneoplastia
después de que se haya ido la hinchazón
esa vez el cirujano reacomodará el
colgajo óseo con placas de metal y
tornillos
y cerrará la incisión de la piel con
grapas
después de cada procedimiento deberá
permanecer en el hospital por varios
días
su cuidador revisará su función cerebral
mediante preguntas y enfocando una luz
brillante en sus ojos
es posible que se le administren
medicamentos para evitar complicaciones